la situación en la planta nuclear de esa
polilla corre otra vez un riesgo mayor
es lo que anunció el alto representante
de la Unión Europea josep borrell
después de que unos bombardeos rusos
desconectaron la central de la red
eléctrica ucraniana
entre estos daños está el ataque contra
la central nuclear de saporilla que ha
sido desconectada de nuevo de la red
eléctrica de ucraniana lo que aumenta
significativamente el riesgo de un
accidente nuclear
éxito aunque esta central está parada
desde
sepchia y no produce energía sus
reactores necesitan estar enfriados
constantemente para evitar correr un
riesgo de accidente nuclear para esto se
necesita agua pero también electricidad
algo que ahora depende de ocho motores
diésel que funcionan gracias a una
reserva de combustible suficiente como
para 15 días más el director de la
agencia internacional de energía atómica
expresó su alta preocupación por el
asunto
Permítame recordarles que se trata de la
mayor central nuclear de Europa que
funciona por sexta vez con generadores
Diesel de emergencia que estamos
haciendo
Esto no puede continuar me asombra la
complacencia sí la complacencia que
estamos haciendo para evitar que esto
ocurra
la central nuclear de saporicha que
producía el 20% de la energía ucraniana
está bajo control ruso desde hace más de
un año grossi lleva meses reclamando la
creación de una zona de seguridad
alrededor de la planta para evitar un
accidente nuclear pero hasta ahora
ningún acuerdo ha sido encontrado